I think the person I'd like to interview
unfortunately has passed away its mother
Teresa and I think that she had a
tremendous influence especially in the
developing world what she did was to
take a group of people that most had
ignored had thrown to the side and she
showed what it's like to make them
equals that they all have the same value
and actually one of the people who also
did that and we're celebrating her the
10th year of her death right now is
Princess Diana and she had a real
connection with the people as well in
the developing world in what she was
able to do was to connect the two worlds
was to bring the people from the
developed world into the developing
world and to make that link she was a
bridge and so the both of them have been
tremendous role models
what can I do to make a difference in my
family in my community and in my country
you